how do you keep up how does the lab keep
up and all these labs around the world
now there's the the doubling of
scientific papers it's just so fast now
there's not enough eyeballs to scan them
and understand them now do you keep up
well a way our task is worse be our der
because we're trying to beat the
interdisciplinary which we don't know
where the next idiosyncratic oddity from
physics or or uh our ethics could or
chemistry could impact our lab so we
have to constantly have I have a lot of
antenna out there so part of the reason
for having a large interdisciplinary
group is that each individual is an
antenna for their these specialties
plural for each person and they may not
be the best in the world at any
particular task some of them are they're
good enough that they can talk to the
the world's experts so that's one way we
don't need everything because we remain
ly doing this for engineering so we need
things that are capable of turning into
something that the rest of the world
could benefit from so that that that's a
luxury and just in in general when you
have a lot of things working you know a
lot of balls in the air that nobody else
has you're not we're not catching up
with other groups we're kind of staying
ahead and in a way that's kind of easier
yeah in a certain way it means we'll
probably make a few more mistakes than
the average group but but we'll have a
lot more warning when new things are
coming on down the pipe because a lot of
those new things came from Marla